- Hey good humans.
I'm Dan Chen, director
of the Jubilee produced
feature documentary, "accepted".
A story that follows four students
at the controversial T.M
Landry College Prep School,
and their high stakes quest
for elite college admission.
We spent the last four years pitching,
filming, editing, and finishing this film.
And we can't wait to share
this extraordinary story
with you as told by the
students who lived through it.
Film comes out on July
1st in select theaters,
and you can also find it
available on Amazon and AppleTV.
Now enjoy the episode.
- [Announcer] Middle Ground
is a social experiment
that brings humans with
opposing beliefs together.
These discussions may contain viewpoints
that are the result of misinformation.
Remember to seek out
experts and to be critical
of your own biases while
forming an opinion.
Please see the humanity
in each participant,
and as always, we encourage empathy.
- My grandmother being
a college professor,
when she and my grandfather
graduated from college
and earned their master's degrees,
they were literally able
to take that to the bank
as a down payment on a home.
A college degree meant guaranteed income.
(upbeat music)
- [Interviewer] Step forward
if you agree with the prompt,
my parents expected me to go to college.
(feet clomping)
- Even though my dad didn't
go to college himself,
he went through a little bit
of an associate's degree,
but his main thing was a photographer.
And then my mom being from
Jamaica, completely different,
education being her way of getting out of
that kind of environment,
poverty, things like that.
She always wanted me to go to school
and they both put me
through private school
to better prepare me for college,
so they kind of started me off on the path
as soon as they could.
- Growing up I actually
didn't even realize
there was an option to not attend college.
I thought that part was mandatory,
but you may or may not graduate.
It was very important to
my grandmother as well,
being a college professor,
and when she and my grandfather
graduated from college
and earned their master's degrees,
they were literally able
to take that to the bank
as a down payment on a home.
At the time a college degree
meant guaranteed income.
- My dad was always the
type of person to say,
get your degree, I
don't care what it's in.
So I always felt a little
bit of flexibility about
what specifically I wanted to do,
and that's why I kind of
took community college
as a time to try a lot of different things
and see what I'm interested
in and not break the bank.
My name is Pam and I'm pro college.
The main thing that I
feel like I missed out on
by going to community college first
was that I wasn't given the opportunity
to pursue leadership roles in like clubs,
or things that I was a part of.
There is a bit of a stigma
with transfer students
that you weren't there
on campus long enough.
I encountered a lot of
people who would discuss
feeling imposter syndrome
or feeling like they weren't good enough
to be at a school like UCLA,
that they couldn't do
as well as the people
who had been there all four years.
And I definitely felt that
feeling sometimes as well.
- [Interviewer] Can the
disagreers or step forward.
- There was no expectation for me
to go to college whatsoever.
So it was really my
personal decision to go.
I saw a lot of poverty in my
community, in my neighborhood,
and so how do I avoid this
situation as an adult?
There was no plan B for me,
so it was like, if I don't do it,
I'm going back to my hometown
and I'll be working at
a factory somewhere,
or I can do it and see what happens.
- [Interviewer] College's
use of affirmative action
is problematic.
(feet clomping)
- Okay.
So my personal experience
with affirmative action
when I went to the PWI,
I was chosen pretty much
based on affirmative action,
there was a lot of heavy marketing,
hey, come to our school,
come to our school.
Affirmative action can be problematic
in the sense that when
these students reach campus
there is no place for them.
- Yeah, it's like, okay, they have clubs,
they have other people that
they could reach out to,
but it's more like once we get you in,
you're on your own,
- You're on your own-
- You gotta figure it out by yourself.
And I also think it's being problematic
when it comes to society,
'cause now you're having a lot of
white Americans saying that,
the only reason this
person got into this school
was because of this reason.
- Especially private institutions,
these Ivy league schools,
certain types of people
attend these schools.
If you don't necessarily
fit their standards,
then once again, you can be
ostracized from that group.
My name is Zakiya and I'm pro college.
Not going to college is
a privilege depending on
who you are and who you know.
I feel like colleges support minorities
depending on where you are.
For me personally, I'm from Baltimore,
there were opportunities for minorities,
of course it's a majority minority city.
If I was in another state
that was maybe more conservative
or predominantly white,
I do feel like I would not
have had as many opportunities.
(feet clomping)
- Meritocracy can't
exist in the same place
where you have nepotism and
legacies and all of that.
But there's always some
sort of an action involved
in getting people into universities.
I personally know someone
who attended classes
at a certain Ivy league university
with a future president and
he was a terrible student,
but of course he got in
because he was legacy
and his family donated a building.
And that's how you become
president, that's America.
Affirmative action is good
to give people an opportunity
who wouldn't otherwise have it.
- I think the intention is good
and you can't speak to intention
when the system looks the way it does.
- We also have to factor in the aspect
of finances and money
and schools making money.
And when we're talking about intention,
yes, there might be one
professor that's like,
oh, I'm so glad you're here,
but that doesn't speak
for the entire university,
that doesn't speak for the board.
Is the intention to give us
minorities an opportunity
or is the intention to
not hear complaints?
- Mm-hmm, to boost their numbers,
boost their diversity levels.
- Well, I actually think
about it differently,
I think affirmitive action,
it definitely works against nepotism.
And I feel like if it were
not on affirmative action,
a lot of black students
wouldn't be able to go to PWIs.
And so I agree that, once you get there,
there is a difficulty
being a student of color
on a predominantly white institution.
With that position it
also was the other side
that would say that same
thing, they would say,
we won't let you in because
you won't be a good fit here,
because you won't fit the culture,
and that's the way that
they would use to bar people
from being able to go.
And so, I won't say, it's
better for them to turn us away
because they don't have the resources.
Let me get there and let me
figure that out for myself,
versus you telling me that
I won't be a good fit there.
And that's what affirmative action allows.
And I also will say,
white women benefit from
an affirmative action
more than any other minority group.
It's not necessarily
about students of color
specifically being allowed on campus,
it's about minorities being allowed.
- [Interviewer] A degree doesn't
qualify you for most jobs.
(feet clomping)
- I think where we're seeing
the world currently go
in terms of the job market is,
a lot of employers are
hiring for experience,
they're hiring to see,
do you know what you're talking about?
And that's where I think
internships really come into play,
and that's why a lot of college students
are going for internships,
is they need to go out there
and get that experience
so that way employers want to hire them.
No employer is going to turn you down
if you are like, Hey, I
have all of this experience,
or Hey, I know how to do
exactly what you're hiring for,
but oh, I didn't go to
college for four years.
- With having that
listed as a qualification
and a requirement,
kind of is like a gate
keeping thing more so
than who's going to perform
the best on the job.
I'm Michelle and I'm anti college.
I became anti college
when I graduated high school valedictorian
and I realized that
continuing on with college
would be a debt sentence.
My godmother actually
gave me a book called,
"The Education of Millionaires"
and she hadn't read the book in advance,
so she kind of thought it
was going to encourage me
to invest in college.
But what the book actually
did was explain the stories
of a lot of people who became millionaires
without formal education.
(feet clomping)
- Most companies don't take
the time to read that resume,
they feed it through a machine.
If you talk the talk
and know certain people
to Jimmy your way in there,
you don't really need the
qualifications to do the job.
People who have the
qualifications don't get the job.
- I've been job hunting
over the last couple months.
I started like a spreadsheet
where I was putting how
many of them are asking for
X amount of years of experience?
Almost all of them were
college degree needed.
I still even got maybe three or four
for every 40 that I applied to.
- I'm originally from Miami
and I used to work for the County,
and I used to work for social events.
And now that I've moved here,
it's really hard for me to transition
towards the same field
because I tell people,
Hey, look, I used to run
football tournaments,
I used to host food drives,
but because I don't have
a degree in marketing
or in event coordination,
people, like you said, when
I put on Indeed, they say,
Hey, you need a degree to get in.
But because I don't have that degree,
I'm not even allowed in the door.
My name is Kenny and I'm pro college.
Going to college is really important to me
because I've had a long
line of family members
who have been educators.
My mom who passed away
from cancer was a teacher,
and when she came to this country,
the only dream that she had
for me was to go to college.
In the early stages of me going to school
it felt like a very hard burden to carry,
the fact that I don't
know what I want to do
when I go to school but
I just have to do it
because it's somebody else's wishes.
But eventually when I started
growing up and realizing that
I have my own reasons
for going to college,
and on top of that as well,
can fulfill my mom's dream
was something that
really kind of pushed me
towards wanting to continue my education
and going to school.
- [Interviewer] All student
loan debt should be forgiven.
(feet clomping)
- It's crazy to me that
you go for four years
and you are paying off
hundreds of thousands of dollars in debt,
and you might actually
meet all of the payments
and you still have like double to pay.
A really popular payment plan
that we've been seeing,
Purdue university started doing this,
it's called income share agreements.
So instead of paying for
your degree up front,
if college actually
helps you land that job,
you start to pay a small
percentage of your salary
over the span of a few years.
And after five, six, seven years,
whatever percentage you pay, great,
if not, and you're not
making a lot of money,
then like the college actually failed you
in helping you get that career
that it was supposed
to in the first place.
- I like that, it puts accountability
on the institution where it should be.
- Absolutely.
- Not the borrower.
- It's very easy to be like,
well, in like the Nordic
countries, you pay $5
and you get your degree.
It's easy, but it's different here,
and it has been, and it will be,
unless some big change happens,
but I don't know what that is,
I don't know how do we
address the millennials
who went through college
and have racked up billions in debt,
and how do we change it
to make it better for our
future generations too.
- And I really think it should be canceled
just because of the pretenses
in which the loans were
actually given out.
It's literally the definition
of predatory lending
in terms of giving thousands of dollars
to someone with no credit score-
- Yeah, 18 year olds.
- Yeah. And so, when they get those loans
and they don't really understand,
the interest is racking up
and then six months after you graduate
and whether you have a job or not,
you're gonna have to
start paying 'em back.
(feet clomping)
- Why y'all? What's going on?
- My disagreement is in
the way that it's handled.
There is this particular
scam which is widespread.
People have gotten
caught up in other scams
and those are not just
immediately forgiven.
Now I do understand
that it's kind of like,
it's a different situation
because of how much pressure
was placed upon you
getting into this scam,
even governmental pressure as well,
which is why they bear
some responsibility in it.
- I was a victim of one of these scams.
I took a few loans out,
and then my last year
I didn't have enough,
and so I took a 5k loan and
that one was the worst one.
What helped me back from stepping
forward was the word, all.
Some people might have
taken out that loan,
gone to college,
and now they're making tons of money
that they can afford to pay it back.
If somebody's capable of contributing,
then why wouldn't they?
I'm Daniel, and I'm anti college.
I took a lot of different classes
while I was in art school,
and I gained, I guess,
a wider set of skills
than my other brother did.
The thing that felt unfair to me was that
it cost the same for us
to go through college,
yet, I got a better return
on my schooling than he did.
And he still has to pay the same amount
that I was having to pay.
If someone's unsure of their career path,
is it worth them going hundreds
of thousand dollars in debt
when they don't know what
they're gonna do with their life?
- [Interviewer] College
campuses are radicalizing
young people.
(feet clomping)
- I hesitated at first
because I was interpreting that as
the universities influencing people,
but I don't think that's the case.
I think people who might
have certain beliefs
are going to college and just
spreading it to their peers.
So in that regard, I
would say college campuses
are contributing to that.
- When you see a headline
and you see that a
college is pursuing this,
or it's agreeing with this,
I feel like it has a lot
more damage towards a story
as if the school is promoting
this type of behavior.
And I feel like because they
notice that a lot of people
are getting a lot of tension
for those specific schools,
it's like, okay, let's give
a more incentive to do it
'cause it's helping
our name get out there.
- If you're not in these spaces
where you're hearing a lot
of arguments from every side,
it's easy to be like, well,
that doesn't apply to me,
so why would I care?
I think for me, at least being
in a college environment,
I was forced to see these things
and more exposed than I
would've been if I hadn't gone.
- When I heard the word radical,
I like paused it for a second
'cause I think it has like
a negative connotation
just in the media,
and so I feel like when
you hear people say,
radical anything,
you're like, okay, that
sounds like something bad.
I feel like it's really the education,
they're learning more about the society
and about the history of
the government in America.
And so that does sometimes make you angry
and makes you want to speak out
and become an activist for
a certain topic or position.
- In my mind though, it's no different
than what algorithms are perpetuating
on social media right now.
If you're on Twitter,
there you're going to be following people
that are within your space
and you're gonna be seeing that content.
And I think that's actually
playing more of a role
in radicalizing and doing
more in the political space
than what we're actually
seeing at college campuses.
- Me personally, I grew
up in a conservative
Christian household.
Growing up in those environments,
I feel like radicalization,
it really starts at home.
It starts with what your
parents tell you about people.
I think that when we get to college,
we're in more of a free
space to voice these opinions
and even on social media,
there's also a level of anonymity,
so people feel more comfortable
sharing certain viewpoints.
I feel like these things start at home
and they're just pushed
more to the forefront
once you get a little older.
- [Interviewer] Colleges
prioritize making money
over providing quality education.
(feet clomping)
- Oh, we all agree how nice.
- As someone who works at a
college, it's a business first,
and I see that first hand.
I think it really does come
down to the bottom line
for a lot of institutions in
terms of them making money.
And so they will make certain decisions
in terms of, what will
allow us to make more money,
what makes us look better
as an institute versus,
necessarily the care of the student
being the primary concern.
- The teachers that I
had at community college
were no better or worse
than the ones at UCLA,
sometimes better.
They were nicer, they
were more approachable,
smaller class size,
more classes available
in community college.
When I got to UCLA, I thought
like there's one class,
and it's only at 5:00 PM.
Are you kidding me?
How am I supposed to make
a schedule about that?
So I kind of realized a lot
of things when I got to UCLA
that like, this is not exactly
what I thought it would be.
- The colleges that I graduated from,
they had a heavy focus on freshmen.
It was all about freshman,
freshman, freshman freshmen.
Bring in more freshmen
because the graduation rate
is already so low.
Freshmen bring in money,
freshmen are there the whole year.
And then if they stay, they stay,
if they don't, they don't.
They were changing all
of the dorm buildings
to freshman dorms, so that
only freshmen have housing.
- Can you talk about the
quality of dorms too?
- Oh.
(all laughing)
Trash, trash.
- For this,
tens of thousand dollars you're paying-
- Terrible.
- Yes.
- How does that make sense?
- Also when you look at public institution
and you see the salaries,
90% of the time you're gonna see that
the highest paid person
is a college coach.
And that'll show you where
the actual money is going to,
and it's like millions of dollars
more than every other person
that works at the institute.
My name is KC I am pro college.
College was a opportunity
for me, definitely,
with the ability to let me outta poverty.
I grew up in a single parent
household, raised by my mom,
and so I think that just
the ability to go to college
and earn a degree,
set me up for higher paying jobs
and the ability to pay my mom's bill,
as well as be a better
person in my community.
- [Interviewer] The college
acceptance system is rigged.
(feet clomping)
- So I went to one of these events
that the school bell
was always talking about
just to learn more about
the admission process.
And my mom ran into one
of these acquaintances
she met from like back in the day,
and he had put all of his
children through the school.
And one of the things he told us
was that the school made
it super competitive
to get in so that their
acceptance rate looks like, 8%.
But for transfers, it's much higher,
like that's the way into,
I would argue most of these schools,
if you don't have the proper grades
or maybe you can't afford it that year,
there's back doors,
and just hearing that I'm assuming
there are more back doors.
- My dream college when
I was in high school
is I really wanted to go to Georgia Tech.
I started my college admissions
process in West Virginia
and going and visiting
the college counselor
on Georgia Tech's campus, they were like,
this is what you need to do,
these are what you need to hit,
this is how many APS you need to have.
My junior year, my parents
moved us to Tennessee
and I ended up applying to
Georgia Tech from Tennessee
and I got denied and I was heartbroken
because I had met all of the stats
that she had told me to meet.
I ended up calling my admissions
counselor at Georgia Tech
because I'd developed a
relationship with her.
And I remember crying with her in the car
and just being like what happened?
And she straight up told me that
if you would've applied
from West Virginia,
from your school, you would've gotten in.
My name's Mehak, and I'm anti college.
When I first entered college,
I thought that you had
to have a college degree
to be successful and to
start your own business.
And I met a bunch of people
that had dropped out of college
that were between the ages of 18 and 23,
that was eyeopening to me
because there were people that had raised
millions of dollars to
start their own companies,
and they didn't have
that college background.
My mom has her master's,
my dad is a doctor,
so for me to turn around and say,
Hey, I actually don't even think I need
four years of college,
I think I can actually just go
out and do things on my own.
It was a big cultural shock for them.
(feet clomping)
- I think about college as like,
what we said in terms of being a business.
And I feel like all businesses are rigged
to make as much money
as they possibly can.
The Institute makes more money
when students are outta state
and paying outta state tuition.
Knowing what we know
about college acceptance,
what would you all want to see?
There's no way that every person
that wants to go to a
particular college can go.
So it's like they have to find
some way to weed people out.
- I think there needs to be
more transparency overall
with universities.
Students really need to be aware
of what they're going to college to do,
who they are looking to learn from,
I think will be beneficial.
Can they learn from them
once they get there?
I'm Kyle and I'm anti college.
If I could do it all over again,
I would choose not to go to college
because there have been several benchmarks
that I can think of where
I've progressed creatively
that have happened
outside of the classroom,
in terms of experience
or things I have learned
from people working in the industry
or lessons that I have
discovered about myself,
just from sitting, doing
the craft that I want to do,
that more or less was
not taught in the classes
that I thought I would be taught.
- [Interviewer] We
should stop telling kids
that they should all go to college.
(feet clomping)
- Yeah, I think some kids,
if they are really, really
excelling in the school
then yeah, you want to encourage that one.
But you'll always have that kid
that just has no idea what they want to do
and that person shouldn't
be pressured to go,
shouldn't even be encouraged to go,
they need to just figure out something.
- Or if their skills are not conducive
to like a normal degree,
- Exactly.
- Or go to trade school,
learn a trade and you'll
you'll make money.
- I think that we need to
switch away from saying,
telling every single kid that
you need to go to school,
more like, Hey, look, if you
don't want to go to school,
here are some other options.
- Yeah, definitely like
more career focused,
more profession focused,
especially in like some of our cases
when we're expected to go to college
and people don't care
what degree you have.
That's a little bit of a red flag
'cause you really need
to be intentional about
the choices you make.
- College is no longer an
indicator of future success.
With the internet,
with just all of this access to knowledge,
you can create your own
future outside of college.
And I think it's really good
for helping you move into career paths
where like doctor, lawyer,
where like you do need a higher education.
I think other than that,
I think it's a lot cheaper
and it makes a lot more sense
for people to find a trade school
or to go to their local community college
and just get the skills that they need to,
so that way they can start working.
- I was gonna say, I
definitely don't think
that college is for everyone,
but I think that most of the time
when we hear conversations
of people saying,
you should go to college.
It's usually from people
who did not go to college,
it's like generic advice in terms of,
you should do something with your life.
That's really what
they're trying to tell you
and they just use college
because I do think it is
still an indicator of success.
I know you said it's not,
statistically you are more likely
to make a million dollars more
than an average high school graduate. .
- [Interviewer] That's a
wrap on the group discussion.
(upbeat music)